el ataque de este viernes en conforman
45 minutos de parís se produce en un
contexto bastante particular aquí en
francia en enero de este año comenzó el
juicio por los atentados contra el
semanario satírico saliendo en enero de
2015 durante las audiencias los
testimonios que se han oído pues se han
conmovido enormemente a la opinión
pública aquí en francia está valiendo
volvió a ser noticia hace tan solo tres
semanas porque el 26 de septiembre hubo
un nuevo atentado terrorista esta vez
donde quedaba en las instalaciones de
charlie hebdo y donde hoy en día pues
funciona una productora de televisión
hasta allí llegó un hombre de 18 años de
origen pakistaní ya atacó a dos personas
que salían de estas oficinas el hombre
fue detenido rápidamente por la policía
y sobre todo confesó los hechos unas
semanas después el 2 de octubre el
presidente manuel masón dio a conocer su
estrategia contra lo que él llamó los
separatismos en especial contra el islam
radical que según el presidente va en
contra de los principios fundadores de
la república francesa en especial de la
y ciudad y luego bueno pues esto se
produce a tan sólo un mes de que se
lleven a cabo las conmemoraciones por
los atentados del 13 de noviembre de
2015 aquí en la capital francesa en los
que murieron 130 personas y más de 400
resultaron heridos